Speaker 1: All right.
A bunch of you sent this to me, and I want
to actually take the time to go through it.
There is a clip making the rounds on the Internet
called Charlie Kirk Destroys Crazy Eco Nut
Student.
That's the title of the clip.
Charlie Kirk is sort of like a Ben SHAPIRO
type character who goes to college campuses,
and he debates college students, and he speaks
very confidently and people in the background
clap and it sort of comes off like Charlie
Kirk is smart and articulate and factual.
Most importantly, it comes off like he's owning
these college kids with facts and logic, and
he's not.
And that's why this format that these right
wingers have developed is so terrible.
So let's calmly go through it.
This is about climate change.
A student who is admittedly not well-prepared
tries to confront Charlie Kirk about anthropogenic
climate change, meaning human caused climate
change.
And Charlie Kirk comes off like he's doing
a good job, but it's all B.S..
Okay, so let's just let's take it one claim
at a time and tell me if this is useful.
Speaker 2: A question will be here.
What's the last question?
Sorry, we got to start.
Yeah.
First of all, sorry for laughing when you
were talking about it.
That's all I mean, because it's just completely
ridiculous for you to to suggest that we can
use carbon dioxide is the only reason why
the atmosphere is heating up.
Okay.
Speaker 1: So already we have a problem.
Can you prove to me that carbon dioxide is
the only reason why the atmosphere is heating?
So we can now calmly think about that.
Number one, I don't know anybody claiming
that heating is the only way we notice climate
change.
We're talking about erratic and extreme weather.
More record highs, more record lows, unseasonable
weather, extreme weather events like storms,
sea level rise, etc..
Okay, so so Charlie Kirk is asking for a defense
to a claim that's not even a good claim.
And the number two CO2 is the cause of climate
change.
We're really talking CO2 is one of the ways
that we see the impact that we're having.
But we're really talking about activities
generating electricity by burning fossil fuels,
manufacturing and industry emissions, which
release numerous gases, CO2 being one deforestation,
using transportation, producing food, powering
buildings they all relate to emissions and
emissions include CO2.
But it's overly simplistic to say CO2 is the
cause itself.
Well, trees need CO2, so we shouldn't be worried
about that.
That's the claim they like to make.
The point is, everything is falling out of
balance.
And when he frames the question in this simplistic
way.
Prove.
Prove that carbon dioxide is the only reason
climate is warming.
We're not talking only about carbon dioxide
and we're not talking only about warming.
Okay.
Next, they move on to sunspots.
Speaker 2: The only reason necessarily also
is carbon dioxide, because there's methane
and there's a lot of other gases.
Greenhouse gases are causing climate change
like this is a huge driver in climate change.
And do you think sunspots have any sort of
contributing factor?
Not to a point where we can say that it's
it's not.
So why is it that.
Okay.
Speaker 1: Sunspots.
Charlie Kirk says, well, maybe sunspots are
the reason for climate.
Change.
Well, climate scientists agree that sunspots
and even solar wind could play a role in warming.
But warming is only one aspect of climate
change.
And the role of sunspots has been studied.
The vast majority of climate scientists say
the role of sunspots is minimal, minimal,
absolutely minimal.
And really the causes of climate change are
industrial activity.
There are thousands of peer reviewed studies
to back that up.
Now you can come in and say, well, all of
the science is just wrong.
All of those scientists are wrong.
And later in the segment, Charlie Kirk does
basically say that.
But now you're arguing that they're getting
everything wrong and good science gets something
wrong, of course.
But is it likely that at this point they're
getting everything wrong on this issue?
No, it's not particularly likely.
So now let's continue.
And now they use it.
Charlie Kirk uses another talking point.
Speaker 2: That it's not.
So why is it that in northern Scotland, back
in the 1700s, they had a mediterranean climate?
What made that change?
The climate fluctuates naturally.
Oh, it does.
Okay, so we have that.
Speaker 1: God.
Okay, so this is another popular talking point.
If industrialization is responsible for climate
change, why was it so much warmer in northern
Scotland in the 1700s than it is today?
Why?
This has been widely studied and there's actually
four of these examples that are often cited.
A northern Scotland was Mediterranean.
There were vineyards in England.
England in general was warmer, and there were
vineyards during the medieval period because
it was so much warmer.
Greenland used to actually be green.
Newfoundland was full of grapes, meaning it
also had a much milder climate.
So it's been studied.
This is not new ground.
The idea with Charlie Kirk is he says this
stuff to people who have never heard of before.
Some of these beliefs are based on tree ring
data.
Tree ring data is not the most accurate for
evaluating temperature since it can be affected
by rainfall and some other things.
But it's something and it's quite possible
that there were some warmer moments before
industrialization.
That's not really a big deal.
Second, it's not clear that in all of these
popular examples Newfoundland, Greenland,
etc., it's not clear that they're actually
referring to the specific places on earth
that we think they are because there have
been changes to the way we as humans refer
to different places.
So part of it is they may be actually referring
to slightly different locations, longitude
and latitude only.
Number three, no one's denying that there
have been periods of warmer and colder climate
over time on Earth.
The issue is that there has been a consistency
globally to the warming over the last hundred
years, and particularly the last 30 years
than at any time during the medieval period.
So you could identify some microclimate differences,
you know, microclimate being like San Francisco.
If you go just north or south of San Francisco,
it's like super hot a lot of the year.
But in San Francisco, it's cooler.
You can identify microclimates, whether they're
Scotland or whatever.
It doesn't disprove anything about the broader
climate change caused by industrialization.
Okay.
Let's let's continue.
Next, they get to temperature fluctuations.
Speaker 2: Here's.
Yes.
This is outside of human emissions at.
No, no, no.
Okay, look to me right now, you're clapping.
It shows ignorance right there because, yes,
there is natural fluctuations in temperature.
However, humans are causing climate change.
We know this.
The evidence shows it.
And you're being ignorant, honestly.
Okay, so what.
What evidence are you talking about?
Speaker 1: Okay, so this is where they kind
of love to wrap you up where you go.
Well, it's only human human activity causing
climate change.
And then they get you to admit, well, no,
there are some natural fluctuations.
Again, you can't fall into this stuff.
Of course there are fluctuations over time.
We've had ice ages and then the ice ages and
nobody's denying that.
What we know right now is that much of the
change that we're seeing is not at all natural.
It's happening much more rapidly than other
natural fluctuations have happened.
And when you look at ice cores, which let
us see conditions going back 800,000 years,
when you look at pollen remains and ocean
sediment and glaciers and more, you know today
that there is much more methane in the atmosphere
than at any time in the last 800,000 years.
These are not little fluctuations that go
with Ice Age or whatever, and we can see over
a longer period of time.
Now, then they get into who's evidence can
you believe?
Whose views can you believe?
Speaker 2: IPCC Climate Change Report.
So 97% of scientists agree that one.
Yes.
The science of democracy is we vote on we
vote on gravity.
We reach consensus the way the scientific
consensus lobbies dynamics and the consensus
on Newton's second law.
Here's the problem I want to know is consensus.
No, it's 100% because it's proven you can't
prove it.
Here's the issue.
Yeah, we don't have an up or down vote on
things like you're not a scientist.
I want to know what the 3% believe.
You know why?
Because usually the 3% dissenting opinion
against the majority is the one that we should
listen to the most.
That's called the scientific method.
Speaker 1: So that's just wrong.
I mean, it's unless you have some particular
reason to believe that the 3% is correct,
then the 97% is wrong.
There's no particular reason that we should
listen more to the 3% than the 97%.
And even that number is wrong.
It's really more like 99.8 and 0.2%.
But that's just that's just a that's a meaningless
claim.
Listen to the minority more.
Why?
Well, I mean, listen to what they're saying.
But why?
Why do we give them more weight?
Speaker 2: I'm pro-science.
You're pro mob ocracy.
You're pro hysteria.
You're pro panic.
And by the way, you're completely ignoring
the positive effects of a change in climate.
For example, the world has never been greener.
Did you know that?
Do you ever know that we have more grassland
and more farmland able to be used for consumption
ever before?
Do you know that?
Speaker 1: Okay, so that's not really true.
What?
That this talking point.
The earth has never been greener.
It's.
It's really only relative to, like, a few
decades ago.
And it it is, in a sense, true that over the
last two decades, Earth has increased its
green leaf area by a total of about 5%.
Now, one of the major reasons for that is
that we're starting with a lower baseline.
The deforestation of the 1970s in particular
left us at a very low starting point.
And over the last 20 years, China and India
have done massive tree planting campaigns.
So they've sort of artificially bumped up
the amount of green leaf areas.
There are questions about whether this artificial
greening has the same carbon capture power
that one might imagine, and the answer appears
to be no.
But this this is comparing to the massive
deforestation of the seventies and eighties.
Let's get now to his claims about the safety
of cold versus hot.
Speaker 2: Use for consumption ever before.
Do you know that less people live in extreme
cold than ever before and this whole climate
fluctuation.
Speaker 1: Okay.
I think he means fewer people, but he says
less people live in extreme cold than ever
before.
They claim that this like it's a good thing.
Heat kills way more people than cold.
Okay.
Way more people on earth have the ability
to heat themselves when it's cold than to
cool themselves when it's hot.
If you look at the availability of fire versus
air conditioning, heat related deaths over
time are estimated to be more than 5 million
people a year because actually no.
Five 5 million is because of extreme heat
or cold.
The majority of that is because of heat.
And heat related deaths are on the rise, whereas
cold related deaths are not in the United
States.
It's also known that heat kills more people
than cold.
And this is even accounting for, you know,
this idea of the homeless person out in the
cold in the winter heat kills way more people.
So the idea that it's good for humanity, it
doesn't make any sense whatsoever.
Let's listen to the last bit.
Speaker 2: Nonsense.
We're only dealing with a 100 year data set.
We know that the world that the climate naturally
fluctuated.
Speaker 1: Okay, so that's the last thing
I'll talk about.
The 100 year dataset.
What they mean when they say that is that
modern historical weather and temperature
records only go back to about the 1880s.
It's like 140, 150 years.
So it's true that modern weather data only
goes back that far when people started measuring
temperature more or less the way we do now.
But as I mentioned before, we have 800,000
years of ice melt cycles.
We have glacier data that's much older.
We have oceans sedimentary data, pollen layers
and more things.
So the kid confronting Charlie Kirk is unprepared,
no question whatsoever.
But the arguments that Charlie Kirk makes
are all bad.
And in that format, there's no opportunity
to really explore it.
But when you break it down piece by piece,
you see that that is exactly what it is.
It's simply nonsense.
Let me know if these types of clips are useful.